public sénat en partenariat avec le
magazine historia vous présente il était
une loi quand le sénat écrit l'histoire
[Musique]
pour 315
contre 249 l'assemblée nationale a
adopté la loi sur le pacs c'est une
bataille parlementaire à nul autre
pareil le 13 octobre 1999 la loi sur le
pacte civil de solidarité est adoptée
après plus d'un an de débats acharnés et
de rebondissements spectaculaires à
l'assemblée nationale est ici au sénat
cent trente deux heures et quinze
minutes de discussion en séance plus de
deux mille amendements 14 motions de
procédure bref un déluge de mots pour
une petite phrase toute simple presque
banal quand on allie aujourd'hui dans
notre code civil le pacs est un contrat
conclu par deux personnes physiques
majeures de sexe différent ou de même
sexe pour organiser leur vie commune si
cette bataille fut aussi longue aussi
âpre aussi riche en invectives en
émotions en coups tactiques en arguments
de fond c'est qu'elle posait des
questions essentielles sur la nature des
liens qui font un couple sur l'égalité
des droits sur la tolérance au fond sur
une certaine vision de la société
comment la gauche at elle failli perdre
la bataille du pacs avant même de
l'avoir livré pourquoi la droite s'y est
elle autant opposés et comment cette
conquête de nouveaux droits à changer de
regard des français sur l'homosexualité
c'est l'histoire que nous allons vous
raconter
[Musique]
bonjour patrick bloche bonjour mathieu
croissandeau en 1998 vous êtes député
socialiste de paris et vous allez
devenir un des pères du pacs mais pour
bien comprendre d'abord l'enjeu que pau
c'est toi je voudrais revenir avec vous
sur le long combat pour les droits des
homosexuels et vous nous racontiez
d'abord ce qui change avec l'arrivée de
la gauche au pouvoir en 1981 pour les
homosexuels ce qui a changé en 1981
c'est qu'il y à une majorité de gauche à
l'assemblée nationale un président de la
république nouvellement élu françois
mitterrand et un gouvernement qui ont
estimé qu'il fallait évidemment sortir
les personnes homosexuelles de la
situation de discrimination dans
lesquelles elle était pas depuis
forcément très longtemps un puisqu'en
l'occurrence la pénalisation de
l'homosexualité c'est vichy en 42 et
finalement jusqu'à la loi du 4 août 1982
qui a dépénalisé l'homosexualité
seulement quatre décennies son passe
toute une série de lois en fait qui vont
être passés pour des inventions c'est
des mesures qui touchent je dirais tout
le champ social c'est gaston defferre
qui ordonne à la préfecture de police de
détruire les fichiers des homosexuels
qu'elle détenait c'est edmond hervé
ministre de la santé qui demandent dès
1981 à l'om est de sortir
l'homosexualité de la liste des maladies
puisque c'était considéré comme une
maladie la maladie mentale maladie
mentale et l'eau mais se fera seulement
neuf ans plus tard où ce sera nice et le
port ministre de la fonction publique
qui évitera que les fonctionnaires
doivent être de bonne moralité
là où l'homosexualité n'était pas
forcément vu comme étant une marque de
bonne moralité donc si vous voulez il ya
eu un nettoyage à la fois législatif et
réglementaire qui s'est opéré très
rapidement et de manière en fait très
militante et pourtant des
discriminations demeure et elles vont
surgir
avec la tragédie du sida la tragédie du
sida qui intervient à partir du milieu
des années 80 et qui va s'amplifier va
être un vrai drame national ça va
toucher beaucoup de personnes le plus
souvent jeunes le plus souvent
homosexuels et avant tout des hommes
homosexuels
ça va être une tragédie terrible on va
être amené à perdre des amis je dirais
dans dans la fleur de l'âge et parce
qu'elle se double d'un autre drame cette
tragédie du sida qui est le sort réservé
aux compagnons survivants mesure il ya
un drame social vous avez souvent des
couples
d'homosexuels qui vivent ensemble qui
sont souvent malades tous les deux
atteints par le sida et l'un décède pour
peu qu'il soit titulaire du bail du
logement dans lequel le couple résidait
est bien celui qui est en survie se
trouve expulsé du logement alors qu'il
est souvent lui même malade et donc tout
ça crée une urgence sociale à laquelle
il fallait répondre face à des
situations extrêmement dramatique qu'on
était amené à vivre quasi
quotidiennement gars y avoir plusieurs
propositions pendant ces années 90 mais
aucune d'aboutir à une impression que
vous avez un peu de mal à convaincre
l'ensemble de la gauche à commencer par
lionel jospin de prémices à ne figurait
pas dans son programme présidentiel de
1995 le pacs sa figurait pas dans son
programme présidentiel de 95 mais ça
figurait dans son programme pré
législatives de 1997 mais si vous voulez
quand lionel jospin devient premier
ministre dans les circonstances qu'on
sait et se retrouve en situation de
cohabitation
1997 comme c'était souvent le cas à
gauche à l'époque on considère que le
champ économique et social et le champs
prioritaires écoutez ce qu'en dit
elisabeth diouf dans les assemblées
l'agenda devient vite très très encombré
et donc consacrer une partie de l'agenda
parlementaire avec tous les débats qu'on
imaginait quand même
d'ailleurs la suite le prouvera
bon c'était pas évident voilà pour
justin cul te quitte un esprit très très
structuré très voilà il y avait d'autres
priorités mais il n'y a pas fallu vous
pas eu de difficulté à obtenir du
premier ministre on a un script ça quand
même à l'ordre du jour de l'assemblée
moi ce que je vais proposer c'est que
nous nous fondions sur des propres sur
une proposition de lois de l'assemblée
nationale pour qu'on marque bien que
c'était des initiatives parlementaires
oqali il fallait d'ailleurs rendre
hommage puisque ça s'était étalée sur
plusieurs années et est que et que je
vois je lui ai dit c'est une réforme de
société qu'il faut que nous fassions
alors vous allez travailler à
l'élaboration de cette loi que
prévoit-elle elle prévoit une petite
révolution du code civil qui qui va tout
changer
c'est le fait qu'on redéfinisse ce
qu'est le couple le code civil de façon
immuable
depuis toujours
considéré que le couple était constitué
d'un homme ou d'une femme et on va
réécrire le code civil et notamment cet
article en disant que le couple peut
être constituée d'un homme et d'une
femme mais aussi de deux hommes ou deux
femmes en l'occurrence deux personnes de
sexes différents ou de personnes de même
sexe et à part après cela ça va
permettre de tout décliné notamment
évidemment le pacs et puis
ultérieurement
plusieurs années après le mariage pour
tous cette époque vous fait un autre
choix celui d'ouvrir le pacs à tous les
couples et pas seulement aux couples
homosexuels depuis le début
contrairement à l'idée qu'on s'en fait
le pacs contraignant civil d'abord puis
le pacs ensuite était destiné à être
ouvert à tous les couples hétéros comme
homos c'était pas pour faire passer la
pilule dans l'opinion pas du tout on
voulait créer un cadre juridique nouveau
mais ou à fait ouverts effectivement à
tous les couples hétéros comme homos qui
s'inscrit pas dans une logique
communautariste finalement de tradition
très anglo-saxonne on a voulu faire
vraiment un cadre juridique que je dirai
à la française c'est à dire éminemment
républicain alors le texte sur le pacs
doit être discuté le 9 octobre à
l'assemblée et la veille lionel jospin
est l'invité du 20 heures de france 2
regardez on écoute le pacs est un atout
c'est un contrat entre deux personnes
certaines effectivement peuvent être et
sont homosexuels et ont besoin de voir
régler un certain nombre de problèmes de
leur vie commune ne cherchons pas à le
cacher c'est fait aussi pour ça cette
loi ne part pas du tout dans tout dans
tous les sens
abordé demain présenté par elisabeth
guigou et les choses vont se dérouler à
mon sens normalement cette loi sera
votée elle est comprise par les français
mais rien ne va se passer comme prévu
qu'est ce qui se passe le mec qui sort
au magasin ça passe un vendredi matin un
jour où habituellement les députés ont
pris l'habitude de rentrer dans leur
circonscription et c'est vrai que
l'hémicycle est assez clairsemé donc il
n'y a pas beaucoup de députés sur les
brédois ou jupes députés et ça vous le
chantez la dernière il n'a pas donné
beaucoup députés sur les bancs de gauche
ou de droite et puis le débat démarre
cette ve est
tranquille ça devait être bouclé dans la
matinée éventuellement dans la journée
et puis effectivement les banques se
garnissent à droite et du coup
catastrophe nous sommes mises en
minorité et tout commence mal avec le
vote d'une motion d'une motion
d'irrecevabilité
je mets donc on voir
l'exception d'irrecevabilité
qui est en faveur
l'exception d'irrecevabilité est adopté
ça a été très très très mauvaises
surprises on arrive puis au moment du
vote il n'y avait pas suffisamment de
députés socialistes donc le groupe a
passé son travail
pas suffisamment je n'ai pas dit à
l'époque pour pas envenimer les choses
ou enfin
et puis ça manifestait une réticence de
beaucoup de députés socialistes comme un
notamment parmi les hommes les plus âgés
pour certains ça choquait des
convictions religieuses donc ça on peut
respecter
pour d'autres il comprenait pas et enfin
pour pour les derniers
conception de
de la vie personnelle qui les rebute et
certainement j'ai pas je me suis bien
gardé d'aller sonder les reins et le
coeur parce que je voulais qu après
puissent voter quand même donc
donc je me suis abstenu de tout
commentaire
qui représente exactement ce que je
pensais j'ai joué
la compréhension ou ce vendredi on peut
comprendre c'est nouveau mais on va
reprendre là où on va recommencer donc
on va pas renoncer on a tous cheap et la
gêne des soutiens faut par le premier
ministre
et puis cet accident de parcours va
avoir une vertu immédiate celui de recel
de resserrer les rangs chez les
socialistes parce qu'une nouvelle
proposition de loi va être bientôt
remise sur la table et là jean marc
ayrault va demander à chacun des 250
députés socialistes devenir la cie
individuellement pour les engager
absolument rien eu jean marc ayrault
évidemment comme riner du groupe
socialiste demandant effectivement
chaque député socialiste de signer la
nouvelle proposition de loi qu'on avait
déposé qui était à 3 près le même texte
qu auparavant et elle va fusionner avec
d'autres propositions de loi qui
émergent d'autres groupes
le groupe écologiste nouveau local au
fond après ce camouflet du 9 octobre le
pacte à devenir une bataille collective
junior une bataille collectif ça devenir
une bataille droite gauche haut droite
comme on l'entend et du coup ça va
devenir une de ses grandes batailles
qu'on a connue après tout sur la
contraception texte d'initiative
parlementaire sur les vg texte
d'initiative gouvernementale
c'est à dire une opposition finalement
entre progressiste-conservateur de
manière très classique comme ça se passe
souvent démocratie dans toute assemblée
parlementaire et avec des arguments
totalement opposées qui vont s'échanger
durant une très très longues années de
débat parlementaire avec des allers
retours entre l'assemblée et le sénat
[Musique]
moins d'un mois après le crash du 9
octobre l'assemblée nationale s'apprête
à examiner la nouvelle proposition de
loi c'est un délai exceptionnellement
court mais qui n'a pas empêché la droite
de fourbir ses armes et de déposé pas
moins de mille amendements pour un texte
qui fait à peine plus de deux mille mots
le 3 novembre il ya foule dans
l'hémicycle laurent fabius le président
de l'assemblée nationale mais tout le
monde en garde il appelle les députés au
respect mutuel et à la dignité mais les
débats vont très vite déraper il est
près de 18 heures quand une députée
monte à la tribune pour défendre
l'exception d'irrecevabilité déposée par
le groupe edf devant ses collègues
d'abord médusé puis agacée elle va
parler pendant plus de cinq heures et 30
minutes un record qui ne sera plus
jamais battu l'assemblée nationale
décide ans après cette performance de
modifier son règlement pour limiter les
interventions sept députés c'est
christine boutin nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui
pour débattre d'un texte dont certains
de nos collègues de la majorité comme de
l'opposition
on peut dire dans la presse qu'il
s'agissait du texte le plus important
que notre corps social avait à débattre
depuis des années
si c'est le cas
ce que je crois également alors il n'est
pas exagéré de dire que nous sommes en
train de débattre de conception de la
société de conviction qui peuvent
s'opposer
bonjour que c'est une goutte un bon jour
en 1998 vous êtes députée apparentée udf
des yvelines et vous allez très vite
devenir la chef de file ou la pasionaria
dayraut certains des anti pacs mais
d'abord ce discours fleuve du 3 novembre
comment l'aviez vous préparer
je les prépare est d'abord physiquement
parce qu'il fallait tenir le choc il
faut savoir que c'était la première fois
que l'udf et le rpr qui étaient à chien
et chat à l'époque se sont bien ensemble
en disant parce qu'il n'y connaissez
rien sur les enjeux et il y avait
personne ni à l'udf ni 1er père qui
avait travaillé le sujet et ils ont dit
on va faire ensemble et moi il se trouve
que j'avais travaillé ces sujets là à la
suite des lois bioéthiques de 93 et donc
il maudit faut parler pendant six heures
ou 7 heures en fait j'ai parlé pendant
cinq heures 27
parce qu'il ya eu des interruptions de
séance et la séance était quand même
assez houleuse écoutez le souvenir qu'en
garde la garde des sceaux de l'époque
elisabeth guigou à l'époque j'avais été
extrêmement irrité parce que d'abord
qu'elle brandissait la bible dans
l'hémicycle et trouve ça ridicule
pas besoin de faire ce geste pour
exprimer son en même temps je vais y
avait des opinions religieuses et moi je
respecte ça voilà mais elle avait une
façon très vindicative au fond de
s'exprimer à l'époque mais aujourd'hui
j'ai beaucoup plus d'indulgence parce
qu'après elle s'est beaucoup engagée sur
les prisons et cooke on a trouvé des
relations plus cordiales que ça n'a pas
été le cas bonds est là elle a réalisé
une performance oratoire un tenir cinq
heures et demie au prix je dois dire
d'énormément de répétition très
fastidieuse mais enfin elle a tenu cinq
heures et demie une performance physique
voilà elle a réussi son coup bon en même
temps on savait que dès lors que notre
majorité c'est être soudé tout ça était
juste un mauvais moment à un moment un
peu un peu pénible fastidieux à passer
c'est un texte qui est heurtée vos
convictions ou qui vous inquiétez pour
l'avenir je suis catholique et
naturellement je n'allais pas défendre
l'averse de mes convictions mais ce
n'est pas uniquement ça c'est une
dimension humaine et humaniste pour moi
est la
conviction qu'un couple est formé d'un
homme et d'une femme et c'est certain je
n'avais rien contre les homosexuels les
personnes homosexuelles mais
naturellement c'était facile de le dire
ce qui vous inquiète et dans cette loi
sur le pacs c'est que c'est un texte
fondateur pour la suite bien sûr c'est
un texte fondateur monsieur bloche a dit
une chose à laquelle j'adhère
complètement il a dit c'était un texte
le quatrième texte fondamental de la
vème république
après la loi neuwirth la loi veil et le
divorce par consentement mutuel le pacs
était un texte fondamental sociétale de
la vème république parce que vous
pensiez à l'époque précisément que ce
texte à lyon nantes rennes et d'autres
je l' ai dit plusieurs fois c'était les
prémices
du mariage homosexuel parce qu'en
réalité
ça a été la première fois où vraiment
façon très profonde on touchait le droit
naturel l'homme et la femme qui ont des
enfants on se lever le tabou de cela et
c'était certain que ce pacs pour lequel
on cachait que c'était fait pour les
homosexuels mais en fait c'était
effectivement fait pour les jeunes
homosexuels mais ça conduirait parce que
la logique de situation entraîne des
logiques de fête et de loi c'est ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui le reste merci de
faire remarquer vingt ans plus tard
alors au cours des débats plusieurs
députés de droite vont tenir des propos
très virulents je vous en cite quelques
uns c'est pierre lellouche qui dira par
exemple à propos des couples homosexuels
il n'y a qu'à les stériliser dominique
dord qui proposera de façon ironique
qu'on enregistre les pacs à la direction
des services vétérinaires ou encore
philippe de villiers qui estime que le
pacs c'est tout simplement le retour à
la barbarie avec le recul vous les
trouvez homophobes ses phrases vous le
regrettez vous trouvez que la droite a
été trop loin
ces propos sont scandaleux et sont
inacceptables et je vais rejette
totalement voilà donc moi je peux pas
vous dire mieux c'est ce que je pensais
pendant le discours que je voulais vous
je dise devant ça je n'ai rien à dire je
vais pas relevé mais je me permettais de
vous le dire dans une ambiance calme et
bien je je je rejette totalité de ses
propos dans votre discours vous aviez
fait cette définition de l'homosexualité
qui a beaucoup choqué certains alors
qu'est ce que c'est
sinon
l'impossibilité
d'une personne à pouvoir atteindre
l'autre dans sa différence sexuelle
aux
caisses que l'impossibilité d'atteindre
l'autre dans sa différence
qu'est-ce que l'impossibilité de ne pas
accepter la différence qu'est ce que
c'est que la possibilité de ne pouvoir
atteindre la différence sinon
l'exclusion qu'est ce que vous vouliez
dire parlant parce que je pense
personnellement profondément
c'est que la différence est une richesse
et le fait d'être homosexuel c'est se
priver de la différence sexuelle mais il
peut y avoir une altérité individuel au
delà de la question du genre ah oui non
mais ça peut être amoureux d'un homme ou
d'une femme quand on est une femme et
découvrir une forme de différence ah bah
écoutes je suis pâmé sexuellement quand
on est deux femmes en et de femmes quand
on dit deux enfants des deux hommes afin
franchement là je je vois pas non ça je
n'adhère pas du tout à ça si vous voulez
dans cette différence
d'accéder à la différence sexuelle de
l'autre il y as pour moi une faiblesse
il y a une faiblesse et un honoré
schisme ans et malgré tout ce que l'on a
pu dire et merci de me permettre de le
dire
moi j'ai toujours été animé par la
fragilité et la faiblesse et donc j'ai
beaucoup d'amitié pour les homosexuels
je n'ai absolument pas de rejet pour les
homosexuels est ce que vous comprenez
avec le recul que certains homosexuels
ou d'autres aient pu être choqués par
cette définition de l'homosexualité
c'est le terme certains parce que pas
tous justement
sans faire de jugement hâtif je pense
que ceux qui ont été blessés
parce que ce n'était pas mon intention
c'est ce que je pense qu'ils ont été
blessés parce qu'ils étaient militants
de la cause homosexuelle
comment voulez vous qu'un catholique
soit hostile aux homosexuels mais c'est
pas possible mais quand et comment est
ce qu'on ne peut pas comprendre cela un
homme et sexuelle c'est une personne qui
est fait à l'image de dieu comme vous et
comme moi et il est autant aimés de dieu
que vous l'êtes et que je suis à droite
une autre fin va faire entendre une voix
bien différente c'est roselyne bachelot
elle sera d'ailleurs la seule députée de
droite a voté le texte avec la gauche je
vous propose de les goûter aussi qui
mieux que des homosexuels pouvaient à
partir de leur expérience de solitude de
rejet de mépris faire le diagnostic des
difficultés qui ronge notre société
ils et elles ne veulent ni le dégoût des
saintes nitouches ni la commisération
des dames patronnesses cela a été
l'honneur de ces associations de faire
des préconisations qui refusaient les
solutions communautariste forcément
stigmatisante pour bâtir un projet où
chacun et chacune d'entre nous pourra se
retrouver lui ses enfants ses parents à
un moment ou à un autre de sa vie car
finalement nous ne reconnaissons ici
qu'une communauté la république
ni sainte nitouche ni dames patronnesses
c'est vous qu'elle vise roselyne bosch
ça ça semble évident ça mais bon c'était
facile de toute façon rosine avait
choisi le bruant moi j'étais dans le
mauvais camp aller dans le glauque en
déringardiser tour les blessures des
regards puis ça m'a collé à la peau pas
mal m'en fasse est prêt à payer que si
vous voulez le 2 décembre lors de la
séance de questions au gouvernement
alors là lionel jospin premier ministre
est excédé il va s'en prendre à vous son
vous nommez il arrive dans la vie
politique monsieur muselier
comme dans la vie parlementaire des
moments plus ou moins facile si je
prends quelques épisodes par exemple le
pacs je constate que pour l'essentiel
c'est
l'obstination dans l'obstruction c'est
le choix de confier sa vision de ce
problème de société à une députée
marginal sur ces questions et
outrancière dans ses propos qui a créé
des problèmes
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous en avez pleuré vraiment
ah oui mais vous savez j'étais fatigué
et je m'attendais pas du tout à ça tout
d'un coup monsieur monsieur jean spa
prend la parole répondant je ne sais
plus quel député lmh attaque mais
c'était pas du tout à la question du
député il avait envie de se payer boutin
quoi je pense que c'est ça et je suis
tombé de ma chaise mon fauteuil et j'ai
pleuré où effectivement il douste-blazy
ou concernés mais qu'est ce qui vous
fait le plus mal dans les propos de
lionel jospin l'époque c'est outrancière
dans ses propos ou marginal dont deux
aux pros quand les deux tiers les deux
parce que je n'étais pas outrancière mes
collègues l'ont été mais moi je n'ai pas
été une transfère dans mon propre aux
imaginales je n'étais pas du tout à
l'époque l'opinion était assez favorable
à ma posture alors vous saviez que vous
alliez perdre sur le terrain
parlementaire d'une certaine façon par
le jeu de la majorité et des navettes
parlementaires est ce que votre objectif
à vous c'était plutôt de remporter la
bataille dans l'opinion oui avait bien
sûr il y avait bien sûr ça bien sûr des
restes j'ai organisé une manifestation
était important puisqu'on avait l'image
de ringard il fallait qu'on donne une
image est du reste on a été les
premières manifestations comme ça
fallait qu'on donne une image de but de
gaieté de joie de joyeux de moderne du
moment donc il y avait beaucoup de
jeunes de réserver beaucoup de jeunes on
à raconter des fadaises là encore
l'histoire des au bûcher c'est
quelque chose qui a été mis par des
militants homosexuels
c'était pas du sein des gens qui faisait
partie de la manifestation
alors c'est un slogan que des
journalistes diront avoir entendu et
avoir lu sur certaines banderoles à
l'époque il y en a un autre qui étaient
filmées qui a été vu qu'ils étaient
entendus c'était pas deux neveux pour
les tons tous nous avions bien calibré
cette manifestation puisqu'il n'y avait
que des des pancartes officielles celles
qui ont été écrites à la main ou d'une
autre façon que celle des officiels ce
sont des initiatives personnelles et
privées que nous cautionnons pas pour
christine boutin et le collectif anti
pacs le pari question mobilisation est
partiellement atteint au trocadéro les
militants d'act up ont brandi une
banderole dénonçant l'homophobie des
participants une banderole violemment
arraché par une poignée de manifestants
qui s'en sont également pris à notre
équipe bousculade il pied intimidation
pour quelques-uns à avoir perdu leur
sang froid c'est dans cette ambiance
très tendue que le texte est transmis au
sénat qui doit l'examiner au moins de
mars ça laisse du temps la droite
majoritaire à la haute assemblée
d'affûter ses arguments la commission
des lois a programmé une longue liste
d'audition 80 personnes au total et
surprise rien ne se passe comme prévu
les associations influente dans la
communauté homosexuelle ne se prive pas
de dire tout le mal qu'elle pense du
texte certaines le trouve mal rédigé un
complet d'autres estiment qu'il ne va
pas assez loin les opposants au pacs
boivent du petit lait confiants les
sénateurs de droite choisissent de ne
pas reproduire les excès de leurs
collègues députés au palais bourbon et
de porter le débat sur le fond mais ils
vont trouver face à eux des sénateurs de
gauche bien décidés à leur répondre vous
voulez changer de posture que dans le
seul but de rien ne change mme et l
agilité intellectuelle du rapporteur
patrice gélard nous en serions restés à
la récitation laborieuse et pétrifié de
votre catéchisme sur la famille immuable
le mariage inchangés comme nous l'avons
entendu d'orateur en orateur
oubliant que la famille le mariage ont
une historicité qu'elles n'ont pas
toujours été ce que vous défendez et
hiboux si vous cherchez
poursuivez
poursuivre et c'est pas moi qui cherche
à faire entrer la bible
vous bien bonjour jean luc mélenchon
bonjour en mars 99 vous êtes sénateur
socialiste de l'essonne et le texte sur
le pacs arrive au sénat après des débats
très tendue à l'assemblée nationale et
pour vous c'est pas tout à fait un texte
comme un autre parce que vous avez été
le premier parlementaire français a
déposé une proposition de loi pour une
forme de partenariat civil dix ans plus
tôt on a retrouvé votre proposition de
loi à l'époque et le mot homosexuel n'y
figure pas nous relations de même sexe
parce que c'était tabou parce que vous
aviez déjà dépassé cette pièce bah moi
j'étais sur un autre plan mais je veux
pas faire le malin c'était pas facile à
l'époque j'ai fait le tour pour trouver
des gens ici au sénat on voulait pas en
entendre parler disons que dans le
groupe alors il ya eu toujours des
bonnes raisons à ceux du pas de calais n
10 heures à coude en a d'autres sujets
quand même nous qui intéresse les gens
c'est les travailleurs ou bien c'est
l'agriculture où il était toujours une
bonne raison pour dire up puis les gens
comprennent pas ce truc là tu ça va pas
le faire mais je vous garantis que j'ai
dû aller les chercher avec les dents du
coup votre proposition fait pschitt
complètement mais
mais j'ai été contente d'avoir fait est
alors neuf ans plus tard donc le texte
du pacs arrive ici dans une ambiance
assez surchauffe et un dans le pays
qu'est ce qui se joue pour vous à
l'époque dans la bataille du pacs est ce
qu'on est sur un affrontement gauche
droite classique ou c'est ce que qu est
ce que c est ce que c'est quelque chose
de plus profond et je pense que ce n'est
pas vrai qu'à l'époque tous les gens de
droite auquel je m'affranchis ici au
sénat qui est quand même lors leurs
terrains de camping gratuite est bon
et est hostile ce n'est pas vrai il y en
avait été horriblement hostile mais pour
des raisons comment vous dire que
finalement une chose dans l'autre je
peux respecter ceux qui sont animés par
la foi religieuse par exemple sont
toujours dans une erreur je leur dis
amicalement
l'autorisation de faire un couple
homosexuel n'est pas l'obligation de le
faire
donc ce que nous faisons c'est une
liberté si bien que en quelque sorte le
libre arbitre qui compte quand même dans
la foi religieuse et la responsabilité
devant dieu qui est totale dans l'art
dans la religion n'est pas effacée au
contraire
faut bien comprendre que c'est ce qui a
de plus intime la formation du couple et
la relation à la mixité et par
conséquent c'est là que vous allez
toucher ce qui constitue la personne
mais les propos qui étaient tenues
étaient à certains moments tellement
caricaturaux plus pour moi il y avait un
certain plaisir il ya comme une forme de
gourmandise parce que vous ne laissait
rien passer à la droite les messages
étaient en trombe au débat pour laisser
passer quoi que ce soit puis si vous
voulez sera un des plus grandes de ce
qu'ils disent est bon à un moment donné
je sais pas moi il était chez les
homosexuels si on écoutait et nouveau
qu'en droit c'était plus des êtres
humains on leur dit oui oui une famille
c'est comme ci comme ça vous croyez
qu'ils n'ont pas de famille justement
votre question sur la famille c'est
l'intervention vous faites au sénat on
va la regarder ah bon d'accord
et nous jugeons à la fin que
quelques-uns des propos qui ont été
tenus ici sont insultants pour nous
croyez vous que nous n'ayons pas de
salir que nous l'aimions pas croyez vous
que les homosexuels n'en ai pas qu'est
ce qui nous vaut de mériter vaut le sens
nous ne les supporte pas aujourd'hui de
notre côté nous touchons au but
d'une façon ou d'une autre j'estime que
ceux qui ont voulu ce combat ont déjà
gagné l'essentiel de la partie sur le
plan moral en effet plus personne à part
quelques énergumènes n'ose dire
ouvertement que le couple homosexuel est
en soi condamnable ni qui l'attend aux
bonnes moeurs à la morale ou même à
l'essence de la société plus personne
sauf monsieur scellier qui n'a pas
manqué hier de renvoyer ce projet de loi
à l'augmentation des pathologies de la
société c'est une chose qu'il faut
pouvoir oser devant une assemblée comme
la nôtre plus personne n'ose contester
que de tels coups de puisse avoir des
droits et que les violences qu'ils
auront été faites soient dorénavant
inadmissible c'est cela qui est dans ce
texte vous garder un souvenir musclée de
cette intervention le sénat a quelque
chose de très franc de très rude à
l'époque ont été élus pour neuf ans donc
si vous voulez il n'y avait pas d'enjeu
de pouvoir vous pouviez y aller franco
et personnes se gêner alors c'était
toujours dans des formes
qui nécessitait une certaine élégance
oratoire oui davantage qu'elle a semblé
à ben moi la première fois que j'ai mis
les pieds à l'assemblée dit scandalisé
la violence des propos tout cris en même
temps au sénat aussi un crime est patent
et puis c'est mortel le sénat vous
tomber sur des gens qui sont des supers
spécialistes de leur domaine et si vous
tromper mais dont je veux vous êtes mort
et est-ce que vous avez l'impression
vous à la fois à gauche et peut-être
aussi à droite d'enclencher quelque
chose d'irréversible avec le pacs pour
ma part je n'ai jamais cru à
l'irréversibilité des lois qui portent
sur des sujets de cette nature mais
puisque ce que je veux surtout vous dire
c'est que ce n'était pas feinte la
colère d'un certain nombre de ceux qui
s'opposent à moi à ce moment-là c'est un
procédé rhétorique que j'utilise quand
je dis oui maintenant tout le monde est
d'accord c'était évidemment pour
marginaliser ce qui ne l'était pas c'est
pas vrai qu'à cette époque tout le monde
trouve ça normal c'est pas vrai alors
maintenant oui mais alors est-ce que
c'est irréversible
non est-ce que ce qui a été acquis il a
été oui parce que même les pires râleurs
n'oseront pas dire à beaucoup ton va
abroger ça vous savez bien de
pratiquement tous lui ont renoncé alors
dans les débats au sénat une autre voie
de gauche va compter c'est celle de
bertrand delanoë qui était la première
personnalité politique à rendre publique
son homosexualité à la télévision
alors quand le sénateur de paris prend
la parole dans l'hémicycle du sénat
quelques mois plus tard sa voix prend
une résonance particulière regardez
c'est reconnaître j'entendais toujours
beaucoup parlé tout à l'heure
d'orientation sexuelle
ne parlait pas que d'orientation
sexuelle il y à du lien amoureux il y a
le droit à la tendresse est tout
simplement la dignité de chacun le pack
se reconnaît l'universalité du lien
amoureux c'est pourquoi avec sérénité
nous soutenons ce projet honorable parce
qu'il renforce le lien social et parce
qu'il représente un progrès d'ordre
philosophique
non il ne peut être réduit à des
considérations exclusivement financière
ou technique
oui ce texte a également une portée
symbolique
la beauté de l'intervention de bertrand
delanoë et la force c'est que il
intervenait en excipant du lien amoureux
et je pense que
c'était très courageux de sa part très
courage et dans une enceinte comme le
sénat et dont il a libéré la parole et
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on lui doit
lui parce que cet acte c'est lui qui l'a
posée le premier et puis ensuite parce
que il a dit l'essentiel que non ce
n'était pas un sujet technique au fiscal
à quoi tous les autres auraient bien
voulu qu'on imite la conversation on lui
doit tous quelque chose ce jour là je
voudrais qu'on regarde maintenant un
autre extrait de votre intervention qui
était dans votre conclusion regarder ce
que je crois que nous sommes en train de
faire
pax parité limitation du cumul des
mandats c'est une révolution culturelle
tranquille qui fait que la gauche est
bien à sa place est bien dans son rôle
dans le travail qu'il est en train
d'accomplir
[Applaudissements]
vous parler de révolution culturelle
tranquille
pacifique et du cac
mais c'était pour dire qu'il n'y avait
pas de barricades ni de coups de feu et
et vous dites aussi la gauche est à sa
place oui la gauche était à sa place
quand elle instaurer davantage de
liberté et de droits pour le droit et de
respect pour la personne humaine
maintenant
des gens de droite pouvez parfaitement
être à leur place dans dans cette
attitude parce que bon nous pouvons
aussi partager ça alors ça n'est pas la
propriété exclusive de la gauche il me
semble qu'il serait tout à fait
contraire l'esprit de gauche de refuser
cette liberté mais ce n'est pas réservé
parce que certains on voit aussi dans ce
pack ce l'amorcé d'un virage de la
gauche et du parti socialiste en
particulier vers des préoccupations plus
sociétale que sociale ues ça c'est une
invention de la petite bourgeoisie
enragés qui aiment bien inventer des
catégories pour expliquer pourquoi il ne
fait rien dans les élections et que
s'étonne ensuite des désastres qui
s'ensuivent quand on crée une liberté
quand on est pour l'égalité sociale au
nom de quoi serait ton contre l'égalité
des droits et en quoi est ce une liberté
aussi et al pourquoi on distingue les
deux il n'y a pas de distinction entre
les deux qui veut la liberté un endroit
l'aveu à l'autre
[Musique]
alors que la gauche donne de la voix au
sénat la droite qui est majoritaire a
entamé une consciencieuse opérations de
détricotage du texte son objectif est
simple supprimer purement et simplement
le pacs en le vidant de son contenu pour
le remplacer par une extension du
concubinage bonjour jean jacques hyest
bonjour en 1999 vous êtes sénateur union
centriste de seine-et-marne quel était
l'état d'esprit de majorité sénatoriale
à l'époque tout le monde était opposé au
texte à droite toujours été hostile aux
pattes
sauf quelques individualités vous même
vous y étiez opposé ah oui bien entendu
je pensais que le texte était mal foutu
et ne répondait à aucun critère
juridique sérieux vraiment
c'était de l'improvisation totale
c'était purement d'affichage politique
au printemps 1999 le débat public il est
encore marqué par ce qui s'est passé à
l'assemblée nationale oui oui vous au
sénat vous choisissez de faire des
choses de façon un peu différente en
première lecture à l'assemblée c'avait
été extrêmement agitée c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire
au sénat c'est pas le c'est pas là la
méthode sénatoriales donc vous n'étiez
pas dans l'opposition systématique non
enfin il fallait essayer de trouver des
réponses concrètes à des personnes qui
n'avaient pas de solution
pour une union
stable disant voilà et donc d'où
l'invention
qu'on doit notamment à patrice gélard de
dire on va créer une sorte de de
concubinage améliorée c'est ça que vous
détricoter le texte va clairement voyez
vous proposer en substitution ouais un
concubinage qui serait ouvert aux
homosexuels d'une c'est ça je crois
qu'il faut être tout à fait clair la
volonté de ceux qui vont voter
l'amendement de la commission
est d'ouvrir ce qui était pas permis par
la jurisprudence jusqu'à présent aux
couples homosexuels la possibilité de
vivre en concubinage et d'être reconnus
comme tels
c'est la condition bien entendu
pour que la plupart d'entre nous vote la
mode en quoi c'était différent du pacs
ce concubinage 1 parce qu'il offrait ce
un certain nombre de garanties notamment
parce que le pacs a cette
caractéristique c'est un
impact on dit même pas un contrat
alors que en droit français quand on
quand il ya deux personnes là c'est un
contrat
où il n'y a pas d'engagement
dans la durée
j'avais même dit on réinvente la
répudiation parce que un seul des
membres du pacs avait décidé d'arrêter
du jour au lendemain alors le problème
c'est que si on ouvre le concubinage aux
homosexuels à l'époque mais il faut bien
l'écrire quelque part oui et vous vous
étiez personnellement favorable à ce
qu'on rédige un amendement pour préciser
qu'il pouvait se nouent et se conclut
nage sans distinction de sexe oui bien
sûr mais ça va être refusé par la
majorité sénatoriale oui pourquoi
enfin ce que le vouliez ou non
l'homophobie existe de même surtout si
on l'a si on ne l'avouent pas parce que
cette ambiguïté elle va être relevé par
robert badinter oui pour lequel
l'expression quel que soit leur sexe
fait toute la différence ouais écouter
les temps ont changé
la société a changé ce qui était ce
climat homophobe que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure cela s'est dissipée pourquoi
parce que les années ont passé et que
face à l'épreuve du sida la communauté
homosexuelle a fait preuve de beaucoup
de courage et de dignité alors qu'est ce
que nous demandons à un faveur de ces
quatre mots quel que soit leur sexe que
de dire simplement ce qui est la réalité
il y a des concubins hétérosexuels et
c'est la majorité et il y à un
concubinage homosexuel et il est temps
de le reconnaître expressis verbis ça ne
sert à rien ces précautions sauf à
laisser entendre que l'on s'y résignent
bon je dirais presque contre son
sentiment profond alors comme je ne veux
pas croire que ce soit cela qui anime la
majorité du sénat je lui dis le moment
est venu pour elle de tourner cette page
il avait raison robert badinter a
vraiment non plus parce que il met enfin
robert badinter il sait très bien
argumenté
et quelquefois il va trop loin il pas
dans ses explications
c'est pas parce que les robert badinter
qu'il a toujours raison j'aurais dit
quoi c'est pas un prophète
ou vous nous parler d'homophobie à
l'époque dans la majorité sénatoriale
vous en avez été témoin dans une
minorité de le braillard
et on a relu mais suffisamment braillard
pour que on refuse d'écrire noir sur
blanc que ce concubinage été et est
ouvert aux personnes de même sexe non
mais en fait ce que ce que voulait faire
le sénat c'est éviter de poser le
problème spécifique
spécifique pour les homosexuels voilà
c'était une loi pour l'opinion cette loi
sur le pacs non c'était pour loi pour
une clientèle m'excuser mais c'est pas
gentil mais c'est comme ça parce qu'il
existe pour vous un vote homosexuels
si vous dites y avait des vues
électoraliste c'était pour conquérir une
clientèle selon humo particulière oui
mais donc il ya un vote homosexuels
maintenant vous un vote favorable à
l'homosexualité ou plutôt un vote
favorable à bière tout ça c'est pareil
une autre critique de la droite porte
sur le précédent que le pacs créerait
nous n'allons aujourd'hui que jusque là
parce que nous ne pouvons pas aller
jusqu'à l'adoption parce que nous ne
pouvons pas aller jusqu'à procréation
médicalement assistée mais on y viendra
ce n'est pas nous qui avons dit cela le
gouvernement bien entendu très gêné avec
ses propositions excessive a toujours
dit mais non il ne s'agit pas du tout
cela ça ne concerne ni la famille ni la
société ça concerne que des individus
toutes les grandes sociétés qui sont à
la base de notre culture et de notre
civilisation occidentale
aux privilégiés le mariage si on me dit
que tout ça c'est ringard
et qu' il faut uniquement se préoccuper
des individus je pense qu'on se trompe
de débat nous on savait que ça n'était
qu'une première étape et que pour les
ceux qui étaient favorables au mariage
homosexuel
ça n'était qu'une étape à l'époque
elisabeth guigou garde des sceaux vous
dis le contraire j'avais pris
l'engagement que ce n'était pas dans mon
esprit et ça ne l'était pas à l'époque
parce que c'était pas du tout dans le
paysage le mariage pour tous à l'époque
c'est tout d'ailleurs les homosexuels
les couples homosexuels ne le demandait
pas donc donc
c'était non ce n'était pas une première
marche et d'ailleurs je leur disais
aussi mais de toute façon si ça devait
arriver si cette demande devait arriver
elle découlera pas même si on vote pas
le pacs elle pourrait arriver donc c'est
pas parce qu'on voit que le pacs couvre
aller vers mariage pour tous je l'avais
assez asticoter sur ce sujet d'ailleurs
elle m'avait dit mme il en est pas
question n'y aura pas de mariage entre
homosexuels d adoption moi je prétends
belle contraire et dans l'opinion vous
aviez l'impression que l'opinion était
partagé ou est ce que vous aviez peur au
fond de passer pour des ringards c'est
un mot qui va bien beaucoup dans les
débats les pouilles bien sûr
toujours défendu me disais que vettel
soit considérée comme ringarde ou pas
c'est parce que c'est pas mon souci il
faut se méfier parce que les évolutions
des moeurs ce que c'est ça refait un
évolution des moeurs est ce que la loi
doit s'adapter à l'évolution des moeurs
et voilà où on en entend s qui a quand
même des par exemple moi je suis très
inquiet
de que la famille ne soit plus défendue
par personne est ce que ce qu'on dit
aujourd'hui aussi c'est que la famille
elle a plusieurs visages est la plus
forcément le format de la famille
traditionnelle vous êtes invités désolé
pour faire un enfant il faut un père et
une mère ça on ne sortira pas ça de mon
esprit
si si si on commence à dire que tout ça
ça n'a aucun sens
je suis un petit peu je suis un petit
peu inquiet pour l'avenir de l'humanité
plus de deux décennies plus tard votre
regard vous diriez qu'il a changé sur
l'homosexualité
je n'ai pas à juger de l'homosexualité
moi je juge pas juge pas
j'en ferai pas je n'en fait pas la
promotion je vous le dis comme ça mais
parce que je sais ce que je fais
j'ai été éduqué comme ça construit comme
ça et pour vous le pacs pour reprendre
votre expression faisait la promotion de
ce type de cette solide bien sûr bien
sûr
autrement il y avait pas besoin de faire
de pacs pour les couples hétérosexuels
franchement où il suffira de la majorité
des packs seront pourtant signé willbold
indique habitent dans les deux années
qui suivent par des couples
hétérosexuels et bien sûr parce qu'on a
offert une possibilité
c'est un droit qu'à profiter à tous si
on veut
après de nombreux allers-retours entre
les deux chambres comme le prévoit le
jeu des navettes parlementaires la loi
sur le pacs est définitivement adoptée à
l'assemblée le 13 octobre 1999 par 315
voix contre 249 au grand soulagement de
la majorité l'assemblée nationale a
adopté la loi sur le pacs
la séance est levée
c'était très émouvant
parce que ça avait été un combat
émotionnel valeurs
qui n'était pas gagné d'avancé
que nous avions conscience que c'était
une réforme de société
majeur et puis il y avait
la joie moi j'ai enfin j'ai reçu des
témoignages enfin de
deux couples homosexuels qui tu es
ça permettait de de restituer toute leur
dignité est ce que ça a permis en effet
le pacs c'est au fond la reconnaissance
des couples homosexuels vous allez
envoyer une circulaire aux greffiers
pour leur dire qu'ils peuvent commencer
à enregistrer les pacs avant même que la
loi soit promulguée points parce qu'il
fallait qu'ils se préparent et que ce
que je voulais surtout pas c'est que des
couples arrivent et que au tribunal on
leur dit pas ce que les gens n'étaient
pas au courant parce qu'il prétendait le
ballet trou parce que un we shall moi
j'ai toujours beaucoup veiller au suivi
des lois que je faisais voter
bonjour caroline forest on shore vous
êtes journaliste essayiste à l'époque
vous étiez aussi une militante vous
aviez 24 ans le 13 octobre 1999
l'assemblée nationale a donc adopté ce
pacs après un an d'une bataille qui a
été très longue d'abord quels souvenirs
vous en gardez est ce qu'il ya eu des
moments de bascule qui vous ont marqué
c'est un souvenir très émouvant pour moi
parce que c'est ma première grande
grande bataille à la fois intellectuel
mans et puis pour mes droits il ya des
moments où vous avez cru finalement que
ce pacs ne se ferait pas même s'il y
avait une majorité de gauche au fond
l'assemblée qui avait peu de suspense
sur le vote final mais il a failli ne
pas se faire elle rappelez vous le le
jour où il n'y a pas eu assez de députés
de gauche pour voter l'ancêtre du pacs
la première mouture on était désespérés
et j'ai organisé avec quelques amis on
était quelques uns d'act up organisé une
manifestation spontanée devant solférino
noms déposés on a bloqué le boulevard
saint germain on était absolument
furieux ensuite on est allé dans le
marais en pensant chercher des troupes
pour pour crier notre colère et puis les
gens étaient occupés à boire des verres
et en fait on a trouvé très peu de
militants pro finale où étaient les
homosexuels pendant la bataille du pacs
il ya eu des gay pride mon appel
souvenir de grandes manifestations
politiques après les homosexuels c'est
pas un corps globalisant mais j'ai il
n'y a pas eu de grandes manifs politique
de la communauté gay si on peut appeler
ça ainsi sauf qu'à l'époque la gay pride
était en soi une manifestation politique
beaucoup plus qu'aujourd'hui parce qu'à
l'époque il fallait un peu de cran pour
participer à une gay pride et puis on
n'était pas d'accord entre nous puisque
y avait plusieurs tendances hocine et au
final on a réussi à tous s'entendaient à
pousser dans la même direction parce que
c'était trop important parce que cette
égalité on avait trop besoin plus de
cent mille personnes venues d'abord pour
faire la fête mais aussi cette année
pour se revendiquer comme étant la
génération pacs celle qui lutte pour la
liberté et contre l'homophobie
tous demandent une loi pour sanctionner
la discrimination dont sont trop souvent
victimes les homosexuels
il ya une partie des homosexuels qui
souhaitent pas se pacsent non plus parce
que alors on dit que c'est l'héritage de
la pensée des années soixante dix où le
pacs au fond symbolise tout ce qu'ils
détestent le patriarcat la monogamie le
mariage mais ça c'est vraiment une c'est
un vraiment une différence
générationnelle parce qu'effectivement
le pacs à partir du moment où il existe
il n'est plus patriarcale parti au
moment où les homosexuels rentrer dans
le mariage le mariage n'est plus
patriarcale et c'est le débat que nous
avons effectivement à l'époque je me
souviens d'avoir critiqué ce que
j'appelle à la posture révolutionnaire
obligatoire mais moi je veux avoir le
choix de ne pas me marier mais je veux
avoir le choix comme tout le monde comme
les hétérosexuels et c'est ce que j'ai
pu expliquer par exemple aux sénateurs
qu'ils m'ont auditionné dans un moment
un peu charnière aussi quand le texte
est passé de l'assemblée au sénat avec
des sénateurs de droite qui je peux vous
le dire à l'époque quand il auditionne
militante lesbienne et les homosexuels
sont un petit peu d'eau ils sont en
train de on sent qu'ils vont passer un
moment plutôt rigolard que sérieux et
c'est en les rappelant à l'ordre de la
république de l'universel de légalité de
ce mot au fronton de nos nos temples
sacrés républicain on a pu capter leur
attention comme moi j'ai senti qu'on
pouvait les convaincre parce que pendant
ses auditions il ya beaucoup
d'associations homosexuelles qui vont
être critiques à l'égard de ce texte du
pacs quel tour incomplets ou qui ne va
pas assez loin
vous vous comprenez qui il est bien dosé
à ce moment là qu'ils ont peut pas aller
plus loin ça c'est l'éternelle bataille
entre réformistes et révolutionnaires
c'est à dire que nous on pense que c'est
mieux un premier pas que rien et donc je
suis pour que l'on vote quelque chose
qu'ils y aillent dans le bon sens qui
t'a préparé l'après mais on n'aurait pas
pu avoir la pression s'était précipité
non plus parce que dans ces batailles là
il ya aussi toujours des raccourcis
possible par exemple en tant que
présidente du centre gay lesbien moi je
refuse un pacs communautariste certes je
refuse un pacs réservé aux unions
homosexuelles
ce que nous propose la droite comme une
forme de compromis or celle inverse une
logique universaliste et progressiste
donc pour vous le pacs c'est pas un
aboutissement c'est la première pierre
de droits à construire nouveau pour pour
les homosexuels c'est une étape qui
honnêtement et celle où on mène déjà la
bataille contre les préjugés c'est là à
mon avis on a affronté plus difficile je
me souviens d'une émission avec le
représentant des maires anti pacs
monsieur michel pinton mère catholique
d'une petite commune qui avait fait une
pétition et beaucoup de bruit à la une
du monde pour dire non vraiment le
mariage c'est fait pour sanctuariser
l'union d'un homme et d'une femme parce
qu'ils peuvent se reproduire et je
l'avais dit en plateau vous faites quoi
pour les couples hétérosexuels stérile
je voudrais demander monsieur pinton si
demain ils comptent installer des
détecteurs de fécondité à l'extérieur
des mairies et à son mari lire n est ce
pas les couples hétérosexuels non
stériles qui est tout le monde tout le
reste toute la masse qui ne reproduit
pas l'espèce se retrouvaient les
préfectures d'un tribunal quand on
regarde vingt ans après enfin deux
décennies plus tard le
les statistiques sur le pacs on
s'aperçoit qu'il a été principalement
utilisés par les couples hétérosexuels
est ce qu'il a manqué sa cible non pas
du tout c'est très bien au contraire
c'est ça l'universalité c'est une
avancée qui est un très positif et je
crois qu'il a contribué à aussi faire
avancer les mentalités c'est quand des
minorités se bat pour permettre une
option plus une liberté de plus pour
tout le monde ah ça permet aussi à ceux
qui ont peut-être des préjugés de se
sentir inclus dans ce progrès est-ce que
vous pensez que la france est moins
homophobe aujourd'hui incontestablement
incontestablement ceux qui pensent que
vivent ils vivent aujourd'hui plus
durement comme homosexuels qui hier
n'ont pas vécu hier jeudi rejet c'est
pas ma génération qui a connu le plus
dur moi je suis d'une génération
intermédiaire mais je suis quand même
d'une génération quand on a annoncé son
homosexualité il pouvait y avoir
quelqu'un de votre famille qui ne
souhaitait plus vous et savoir que vous
ne deviez plus approcher leurs enfants
parce qu'il confondait homosexualité
pédophilie
je suis d'une génération j'ai vu des
gens très proches de moi à penser à
peut-être envisager une intervention sur
l'hypothalamus qui pourrait peut-être
faire changer les rendre heureux
hétérosexuels je viens on a connu ces
mentalités là en 2013 comme en sera une
autre bataille celle du mariage pour
tous et on a l'impression que celle du
pacs était une forme de répétition
générale chacun reconnaît d'une certaine
façon les mêmes erreurs c'était très
étonnant honnêtement après cette période
de stabilisation pendant 10 ans assez
consensuel de revivre la violence de
l'opposition mariage pour tous qui était
beaucoup plus politiciennes qu'à
l'époque du pacs ça qu'on était dans un
contexte où la droite se chercher quand
même une cause pour descendre dans la
rue contre le contre françois hollande
et il y avait beaucoup plus d'
instrumentalisation qu'à l'époque du
pacs ou là c'était vraiment des gens qui
descendait dans la rue parce que savoir
paraissait impossible sociétalement mais
quand même on a revécu des moments d'une
violence et l'homophobie verbal
décomplexée des manifestations j'en ai
subi une physiquement violente qui
annonçait peut-être pour le coup pas
simplement
canon c'est à la fois que l'homophobie
était devenue une minorité dont une
minorité radicaliser et qui a annoncé
aussi la violence de l'époque en général
ce sont des lois irréversible pour vous
le pacs puis le mariage puisqu'on fo
demande rien n'est rien et irréversible
aucun akin était réversible je crois que
ce qui se passe aux etats-unis avec le
renversement de la région oued et de
l'avortement nous le montre bien et
c'est bien pour ça que je suis
personnellement obsédé à l'idée d'être
stratège et d'être généreux et de ne
jamais emprunter des raccourcis qui
puisse générer ces retours de bâton
j'insiste aujourd'hui je vois beaucoup
dans les nouvelles générations de
militants des gens qui pensent plus à
exister pour par eux mêmes et pour eux
mêmes qu à solidifier ses droits acquis
pour tous et ça ça m'inquiète parce que
jusqu'il ya en face je veux dire le
démon de la réaction identitaire qui
renaît de partout je crois qu'il faut
pas jouer avec ce feu là et qu'il faut
être très très très
très conscient qu effectivement ces
acquis sont fragiles
[Musique]
plus de deux décennies après le vote du
pacte civil de solidarité quel bilan
peut-on en tirer eh bien d'abord que la
mise en oeuvre du pacte n'a pas porté un
coup d'arrêt à l'institution du mariage
on prononce chaque année en france un
peu plus de 220 du mariage pour un peu
moins de 200 milles pacs ces deux formes
d'unions coexistent donc davantage
qu'elle ne se font concurrence ensuite
que la droite qui s'était si
farouchement opposée au pack sur un
débat n'a jamais tenté ensuite de
l'abroger lorsqu'elle est revenue au
pouvoir le signe sans doute que cette
petite modification du code civil
s'était déjà bien durablement installé
dans la société enfin et surtout que la
perception l'acceptation de
l'homosexualité ont profondément changé
depuis le vote du pacs celle ci est
aujourd'hui considérée comme une manière
comme une autre de vivre sa sexualité
pour une majorité de français dans tous
les sondages la preuve s'il en fallait
que la loi quand elle est bien faite le
non seulement changer les règles mais
aussi faire évoluer les mentalités
[Musique]
public sénat en partenariat avec le
magazine historia vous a présenté il
était une loi quand le sénat écrit
l'histoire
[Musique]